[Music]
spit that out
kids but also a sid for kevin for taking
such dainty donut bites
i know kevin in many ways i am kevin and
that is not how a kevin takes a bite of
a donut unless he's doing it at
afternoon tea with the queen
so yesterday dwight found half a joint
in the parking lot wasting half a joint
slow moving inattentive dull
dull is a symptom of marijuana use
annoying maybe but i've never found
anyone high on ganja dull
lack of motivation hey
[Laughter]
kevin is great i don't care what you say
i'm taking a sin off for mr malone no
seriously i really don't care what you
say why is pam's reception placard
pointing at the office staff instead of
the door through which
every visitor enters are they keeping it
a secret
i enjoy the tangy zip of miracle whip
doing terrible impressions of your
co-workers or really just doing terrible
impressions in general
also miracle whip and the guys are
saying chug chug chug
but i'm so small what kind of party was
kelly at she's not 19 or anything and i
don't think there are any fraternity
robashes happening in the tiny town of
scranton if anything i'd bet this area
is big on butt chugging
oscar visited mexico when he was five to
attend his great-grandmother's funeral
what does that mean to a united states
law enforcement officer
he's a potential drug mule dwight as a
stand-in for the overzealous and
self-justifying u.s law enforcement
industrial complex is so perfect
i would just take another sin off but
also the u.s law enforcement industrial
complex
have you ever taken any illegal drugs no
i have not sure dwight's an odd duck
when it comes to his daily behavior but
i'm more concerned about his co-workers
since they're choosing to entertain this
[ __ ] and answer is inappropriate and
personal questions
and yes oscar does choose to get up and
leave in a few seconds but he never
should have even answered the question
about what drugs he's taken
have you ever pooped
a balloon hemorrhoids it's marijuana how
do you know that
it's labeled this would be a funny joke
if this sheet of paper in
any way indicated that there was a label
on the picture he does everyone in the
office
considering how hot jim is i can't say
i'm surprised but i
am a little shocked that pam hasn't
reported this behavior to toby and hr
jim is not allowed to talk until after
he buys me a coke no one will be seated
during the pam explains the rules of
jinxing vis-a-vis soft drink purchasing
portion of the episode
where were you yesterday after work
sexual role-playing in the office
in the office is that true toby
oh when you sign your job application
you agree to comply with
random drug testing but random drug
testing means random employees get
tested at random times and not all at
once
so that's not what this is and everyone
could tell dwight to stick the drug test
up his schrute shoot and move on with
her day
also the way this camera keeps moving
quickly to whoever speaking is making me
nauseous
and angry you obviously have several
other cameras here since you basically
capture every moment with a two shot set
up have your doc crew communicate with
each other about coverage
so i don't end up chucking last night's
lasagna all over this new keyboard
also also how do they even know where to
pan to it's almost like they know the
script and who will be speaking next
everybody in the aisle was doing it
wedding orgies you're not
on anything how long have dwight and
angela been hooking up on the regular
you're telling me this has
never come up before i was so nervous so
this time i wanted to be special
jim can't talk but what's keeping him
here corralled by kelly's story
can he not act like he's got a pee or
look at his watch or pretend his phone
is ringing well half his whole character
is giving the camera expressive looks
everybody knows that cheech and chong
are funny but just imagine how funny
they would be if they didn't smoke pot
wait of all the people to react
quizzically to this
obvious boner it's angela how would you
even know who the cheech and chong are
this year more people will use cocaine
than will read a book to their children
to be fair this statistic does not
account for the people already on
cocaine while reading a book to their
children
okay sure that looked like it was going
to be good thing office fans said when
they announced a season eight and nine
somehow made it into the script just
forget it just the urine the hardest
part of the office mockumentary consider
the moments that characters have to say
or do things they would never want to
say or do on camera
for this scene we have to presume that
michael not only left the shades and
door open for this conversation but that
he
also forgot whatever microphone is
capturing this and doesn't spot the
giant cameras filming him directly in
his line of sight
and you know what they say when you
presume something it makes a pre
out of you and you know what just add
this in already
you look like you have something really
important to say and you just can't for
some reason
look we all love jim and pam but the way
this show relies on their flirting to
carry this completely hollow b plot is
nothing short of mercenary this plot was
supposed to be about jim's impressions
damn it and you wasted on this jinx
rules nonsense
you can't just solve that with jenna
fisher's koi smile alone taking an
unscheduled break during business hours
without permission
keeping your wallet in your front pocket
ensure you'll have less back pain long
term but you'll also look like a mega
dork every time you get your wallet
and really what's more important very
nice
great can i have a gun america
why does he do the things that he does
for michael i just don't get it
what is he getting out of that
relationship speaking of not getting it
what a weird end to this episode i think
we're supposed to compare michael and
dwight to
jim and pam here but does that mean the
show is saying jim is an idiot for
flirting with pam is it saying dwight
and michael are going to hook up
i mean i know which one i'm rooting for
but still also do we never find out who
the joint belongs to
michael only says he smoked some cloves
at an alicia keys concert but who left
the joint in the parking lot i need
resolution you can't treat a half a
joint like some sort of story mcguffin
mcpuffin
[Music]
i'll just enjoy this glass of water i'm
stuffed
sinners go vows to our newest domain of
nifty delights and behold commercial
sins
oh and subscribe immediately so the
order goes click sub simple as that
oh actually watch the video jesus i
guess i need to make a flow chart
commercial sans go now
i always did like a manly uniform and
that one fits you grand
but i'm so small and all i'd eat in that
day was one of those anti-m pretzels
from the food court
so i said is it okay if i sip it and
they said no
but ryan seemed cool either way please
shut up dude where's my office where's
your car dude
this year more people will use cocaine
than will read a book to their children
cocaine what's it do
it turns all your bad feelings into good
feelings it's a nightmare
have you ever pooped
a balloon the only logical thing to do
in this situation is to put this
deep in your ass pam told me you do a
great
stanley impression i'd love to hear it
now most people when they find a dead
body in their house they call 9-1-1
well you didn't do that dude it has to
be official and it has to be
urine so
we'll cover our bodies in urine and they
will be virtually undetectable to all
dinosaurs
this year more people will use cocaine
than will read a book to their children
cocaine is a hell of a drug